[Applause]
can somebody tell me
what the record is
for the most points
it was mad reggie they lost
here is the reigning mvp with the ball
moments ago
yogic in a free by curry he's made over
3 000.
here comes
[Music]
year after that and it took so long to
get back to that stage
you know to finally break through and
you know
dallas never had a basketball
championship before
a lot of this is here for trey young
we're talking with dirk nowitzki way
outside three is put in by stephen curry
never forget
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
here we go video game it's video game
time i can't help but think but what you
set in stride for all these players i
think maybe just maybe i could get to
your weapon you know with strength and
cool coach and all these petrovich and
and if i help it's inspired some younger
guys from europe now that's obviously an
honor and i'm humbled
on fire from deep that's eight of 11.
it's just an honor and a tribute to
everybody that helped me get here it
takes a village a lot of people don't
understand the sacrifices that go into
being a professional athlete
down his ninth tray of the eve right
right you know what i mean it's just
honoring him you know i mean just
honoring the people that helped
one leg
[Applause]
i had the opportunity to be a part of
something like that you call it a
blessing i had a few flashback
nightmares
taking over this game with one
beautiful rainbow
a lot of bad memories especially for
myself and i
[Applause]
nba topshop
[Applause]
oh no oh here we go here we go
[Applause]
over two decades and turner and reggie
were his teammate for so many of these
years and d rate he called a lot of your
cage
with all these three thank you steph
curry thank you steph curry korea
historic performance in
[Music]
[Applause]
i can do this 15 threes 45 points
and on a night for the ages he's putting
on a performance
for the ages at the all-star game on tnt
and picked up by the trojan
[Applause]
how about the degree of difficulty just
coming down oh i'll stop right here at
37